after hearing so many stories about
Chicago's segregation I still had one
more question to ask what do you think
people get wrong about Chicago hmm I lie
who everything
[Music]
when people think of Chicago they go oh
my god it's a violent place with crazy
people and that's not the truth there's
this perception that it's the Wild West
out here that people are just on corners
shooting Chicago is a place with a lot
of proud people and people fighting for
justice what people get wrong about
Chicago is the joy there is a lot of joy
in Chicago I don't understand why people
say Chicago's bad or these neighborhoods
are bad when it's really not the
neighborhoods just some people I don't
understand why all of that gets totally
overshadowed by what is real pain as
well but is not the totality of our
existence here in Chicago you know I
think a lot of people kind of count us
out as lost causes or kind of the people
that need help and that's all that they
need they need help they need guidance
any resources any funding I think it's
important for people to know that there
are folks who are in the trenches who
are in this work every single day who
make incredible sacrifices so we're
pulling from a small chain and trying to
help people but we love each other
enough to do that and I sitting around
sad and depressing giving up on each
other I think what people get wrong
about Chicago is that Chicago has always
been a segregated City that segregation
produces misery that misery produces
crime back and that crime is now being
reflected when you don't invest in young
people
you get unemployment
you get crime you get violence so you
get blighted communities when you don't
invest in the people from those people
think that this is only a Chicago issue
Baltimore Detroit Philadelphia urban
places in this country are all dealing
with these same issues elected legacy of
segregation that has roots and housing
equity and violence comes along with
that
it would be great if we had a whole team
of social workers and psychologists and
job training folks to build upon what is
obviously an insistence on life
and a will to live so I think that's
what people get wrong about Chicago
[Music]